>> ♪ ♪
>> Sean: ONE ENDORSEMENT FOR
PRESIDENT TRUMP, 50 CENT IS
ENDORSING PRESIDENT TRUMP AND
URGING FANS TO VOTE FOR THE
PRESIDENT’S REELECTION.
NO POLLING SUGGESTS THAT DONALD
TRUMP HAS JUMPED OVER 10 POINTS
WITH YOUNG AFRICAN-AMERICAN
VOTERS.
HERE WITH MORE FORMER NFL PLAYER
HERSCHEL WALKER AND A RADIO TALK
SHOW HOST.
LARRY, YOU HAVE SEEN THIS WITH
HISPANIC AMERICANS AND
AFRICAN-AMERICAN
AFRICAN-AMERICANS DOUBLING OR
TRIPLING NUMBERS WE GOT IN 2016.
DOES THAT TRANSLATE INTO VOTES?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
IT’S TOUGH TO BEAT HISTORICALLY
LOW BLACK UNEMPLOYMENT.
IT’S TOUGH TO DO WHAT DONALD
TRUMP IS DOING WITH ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS WHO TAKE JOBS FROM
OTHERS.
WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP HAS DONE
FOR BLACK COLLEGES.
HE HAS A RECORD HE CAN RUN ON IT
AND GET TROUBLE OR TRIPLE
SUPPORT HE GOT IN 2016.
>> Sean: HERSCHEL WALKER, IF
DONALD TRUMP FOUGHT AGAINST
INTEGRATION OF SCHOOLS BECAUSE
HE DIDN’T WANT HIS KIDS GOING TO
SCHOOLS HE CALLED RACIAL
JUNGLES, DO YOU THINK THE MEDIA
MIGHT COVER THAT?
>> [LAUGHING].
I THINK THEY WOULD COVER IT
NON-SHEP.
-- NON-STOP.
HERSCHEL WALKER WOULD NOT BE HIS
FRIEND.
I WANT EVERYONE TO IT LISTEN TO
ME BECAUSE I HAVE NOT BEEN
OFFERED A VICE-PRESIDENT JOB OR
CABINET NOB.
-- JOB.
YOU BETTER GET OUT AND VOTE
REPUBLICAN.
AS LINDSEY GRAHAM SAID IF YOU
DON’T VOTE REPUBLICAN, YOU WON’T
RECOGNIZE AMERICA IF YOU LET THE
DEMOCRATS IN CONTROL.
YOUR GRANDKIDS AND KIDS WON’T
RECOGNIZE AMERICA.
THEY DON’T LIKE AMERICA.
THEY WILL TAKE YOUR FREEDOMS
AWAY.
I WON’T STAND FOR IT.
>> Sean: LARRY, LOOK WHAT HAVE
YOU DONE.
CAMPAIGNING FOR DONALD TRUMP.
>> RIGHT.
THAT’S WHY I DID THE MOVIE UNCLE
TOM.
THEY ARE SAYING MAYBE WE OUGHT
TO RETHINK OUR ALLEGIANCE TO
A PARTY THAT ADVOCATES A WELFARE
STATE.
IT’S THE NUMBER 1 PROBLEM FACING
THE COUNTRY AND BLACK AMERICA IN
PARTICULAR.
THE LEFT IS NOT TALKING ABOUT
THIS AT ALL.
>> Sean: HERSCHEL WALKER, HOW
MUCH HEAT HAVE YOU GOTTEN OVER
SUPPORTING DONALD TRUMP?
>> WELL, I REALLY HAVE NOT
GOTTEN ANY HEAT.
I HAD TO EDUCATE SOME PEOPLE.
AND MOST AFRICAN-AMERICANS ARE
BEING EDUCATED.
THEY KNOW THE PLAN BIDEN WON’T
WORK.
I ENCOURAGE EVERYONE ELSE TO DO